ça fait dix ans que vous vous droguer
pourquoi avoir commencé
[Musique]
moi ces buttes les toxicomanes ça nous
permettrait de recommencer à zéro
barre toi
pas facile de demander de l'aide c'est
pour ça que la plus grande satisfaction
de ma vie de vous aider à changer la fin
on est une grande famille vous emballez
pas trop je vais vous avouer un petit
secret
depuis 2008 toutes les assurances santé
de couvrir les traitements des troubles
liés à la toxicomanie dans l'industrie
de la santé on appelle ça la ruée vers
l'or
je veux plus de cette vie de merde
j'aimerais bien faire ce boulot - utah
bienvenue dans l'équipe
bonjour vous êtes au centre de
désintoxication
c'est quoi ça c'est le rêve amis
donc yves en désintox tu touches heures
pourcentage et tu leur enfilent un peu
et c'est tout vu ça s'appelle le
capitalisme
[Musique]
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un compter de
l'argent faisant une tête d'ail
y a pas beaucoup de gens qui arrivent à
faire quelque chose de leur vie
cette
détente one sessad de faire confiance
[Musique]
j'ai obtenu une chambre pour votre fils
d'ornano cendres il vient de se faire
9000 $ en trois minutes dieu est grand
[Musique]